so if you had to choose between two
athletes
uh who would dominate competition one
who drills 100 000 reps of a specific
takedown specific technique
or one that spends that time live
wrestling both um it's the same and i
like to live wrestling i was always
wanting to live wrestle bring the
warm-up into the live wrestle let's go
um but where i got really really good
was a repetition
and i was disciplined enough to know
that the things that you hate
to do in this sport are the things that
make you the very best
and that is a rare ingredient as i've
gotten older and you spend a lot of time
communicating that to younger athletes
so the thing
if you feel yourself hating something
that's probably the thing you should be
doing yes as a matter of fact i had a
strength coach when i was really young
he was just a
freaking guy that would
we wore white like he was almost like a
nurse nurse's clothes he wore all white
from head to toe and he was in cheyenne
wyoming
and his first name was walt
and he taught terry and i to hate the
bar away from you on that last rep when
you're dead
and whether it's a curl you hating up
and then you do the negative and you
hate it down and you hate that bench up
and you hate it you look at the bar and
you hate it away from you
so
you know i learned and that i was young
i was young
and
i remember being bored my mom's sister
lived out there and we were dropped off
to stay out there with our cousins and i
was born a little bit and they always
treated us really good but this was like
the
the single most
bright spot in a weight lifting like
enlightenment even though i lifted
weights
but i never knew the psychology behind
lifting weights it's just to look good
and so you can flex and look in the
mirror or is it for performance
and this guy was about performance
and you said repetition do you mean
technique i'm talking repetition
technique technique technique drill
drill drill hit hit hit drive finish hit
hit hit drive finish so you believe in
that you believe in that wholeheartedly
so i mean i believe that you have to do
it on your own
i don't believe in the coach taking you
to the promised land
so
in the guys today
or in yourself how often do you see
people that
uh grow the belief of doing 10 000 20
000 reps i think it's rare i think it's
very rare and i think it's especially
rare i mean you can talk about that as a
coach but it's especially rare
to
bring a guy to that understanding but
you never stop trying you're always
trying to reach him
i mean we didn't have a good performance
out there tonight but
you know what you don't stop
communicating
and there's a lot of programs out there
that put their head down
when things aren't going their way and
then as things start going their way
then they rise with the tide
there was no difference in the demeanor
that that of our corner and we talk
about that's a philosophy and so you're
reaching your guys that way
um so go back to your point or your
question you know do you believe in the
in the 10 000 reps and yes i do
and how do you inspire people to do that
so well you communicate by example but
communication but i mean that's a
in my experience what i've seen
uh communicating the value of repetition
and drilling is a hard thing to
communicate it's hard and it's very rare
to have somebody that goes in there and
will do it on their own do you have
young guys that step up and do that we
do and it's rare and the guys that do it
on their own and have done it on their
own are the guys that
are in that lineup and and doing well
um the other thing is is that
when you talk about uh getting to that
next level
um a lot of times it's
you know what held you back was i did
everything the coach asked of me and
nothing more
right i mean you can be a great guy for
a
for an app for a coach as an athlete
and you did everything that coach asked
but you did nothing more
so you're really looking for the guys
that
go way beyond what the coaches we don't
want guys that are looking at their
watch running out of the room when
practice is over
we want guys that know what they have to
get done and they might leave early
but they're not looking at their watch
they might be done early they might be
we might be on a whole different path
and this guy just excuses himself i'm
all about that
we are not we are not autocrats there's
an internal engine in there is that
something you're born with
or is that something you can develop i
think you are born with it you develop
it also and i think that there has to be
comfort and then go back to the
communication
that
young people are
comfortable enough to communicate that i
need to take the day off
so what do you mean by communication
just let exactly so letting letting
athletes
uh be part of their own development
communication to me is is is letting
them know
what their what they need to do to get
themselves in contention to be the
starting quarterback
and then to give them
boosts and compliments when they earn
them
and
i don't have time to waste
with
with lies and cheating
and when i say cheating i'm talking
about when they cheat themselves and so
those become very direct conversations
and the conversation starts like this i
don't have time to waste it neither do
you
and so why are we wasting our time and
here's what i mean by that
we're having a conversation about
you know your accountability
if you look in the mirror and you're
accountable then we are we aren't taking
the time to go through this
we're already on our way to solving the
problem problem can't be solved without
that understanding
and that's
has to do with symptoms that you see in
the wrestling room there's something
where the fire is not doing with mental
emotional spiritual physical
everything everything that you know
about you know i had a boss and our
athletic director is a great athletic
director and he gives us everything we
need to be successful but i had a boss
his name was fred mims i didn't think
anybody could be better than him and
then all of a sudden this gene taylor
guy came in and i didn't and then he was
pretty doggone good too and he actually
you know was just like fred and maybe
even a little bit more current and then
he ended up taking a job at kansas state
where he's the athletic director now and
and then this this lady barbara burke
comes in
and i didn't think anybody could be
better than gene taylor or fred mims and
this barbara burke she's better than
both of them
and the reason why is because she's a
problem solver she doesn't waste time
she's direct and she's a problem solver
and that's what we need you need problem
solvers
you